derniers préparatifs pour ces deux
navires s'apprêtant à quitter odessa
sous votre surveillance ils ont été
chargés de dizaines de milliers de
tonnes de maïs et de soja soit une
infime fraction des 20 millions de
tonnes de produits agricoles qui étaient
bloqués depuis février sans compter la
nouvelle récolte estivale
d'après les calculs de notre ministère
de l'économie cela va rajouter encore au
moins 20 millions de tonnes de céréales
voire 25 cela signifie que nous allons
devoir en exporter 45 millions au total
rien de tout cela n'aide les petits et
moyens producteurs qui travaillent dans
la région
les seuls céréales exporté à l'heure
actuelle proviennent de gros exploitants
alors les agriculteurs comme vladimir
doivent prendre leur mal en patience une
attente qui pourrait durer des mois
voire plus
ça c'est la récolte de l'an dernier
c'est du blé d'hiver il y environ 60
tonnes mais je ne peux pas les vendre à
cause de la guerre personne ne les
achètera au port d'odessa parce qu'ils
sont en train d'exporter les céréales de
l'an dernier les silos sont donc plein
donc ils doivent d'abord libérer ceux
qui déjà en stock
vladimir à 300 hectares de terres sur
lesquelles poussent du blé du maïs ou
encore du tournesol une entreprise
agricole qui nécessite des moyens
logistiques et humains il est
aujourd'hui prisonnier d'un cercle
vicieux
de l'essence des engrais c'est tout ce
dont nous avons besoin
on a des travailleurs et de l'équipement
mais on ne peut pas acheter des sens à
cause de ses récoltes invendus qui
dorment dans un entrepôt
vladimir nous expliquer que toutes ces
graines de tournesol vont devoir être
récoltés d'ici deux à trois semaines ce
qui est normalement une raison de se
réjouir pour lui s'est transformé en
véritable angoisse car qui sait ce qu'il
va advenir de cette nouvelle récolte
absolument personne à ce stade